parlons de dossier litigieux je retrouve
les mots du politique pour parler de
Davy Johnson Jean-François vous aviez
comme l'ancien un appel si je me
rappelle bien monsieur Johnson pour
quitter ses fonctions en disant vous
nous dites de faire confiance aux
institutions il y en a une la Chambre
des communes qui va vous envoyer un
message avez-vous donc été surpris de sa
décision de rester en poste
j'ai été déçu j'étais déçu je pense que
il y avait envoyé un signal dans sa
lettre au double vendredi en disant que
personne ne le ferait modifier sa
décision d'aller jusqu'au bout de son
mandat personne ça veut dire la majorité
des élus à la Chambre des communes donc
je pense que
ça va être une très très mauvaise note
dans sa biographie de voir que cet homme
d'institution a refusé de se plier à la
volonté même si on peut dire c'est
partisans puis c'est pas une bonne idée
etc mais quand tu perds la confiance de
la Chambre du père de confiance de la
Chambre peu importe les raisons qui ont
poussé la chambre à retirer la confiance
et en fait il y avait de très très
bonnes raisons de retirer sa confiance
que tout ce dont on avait discuté depuis
le début mais aussi ce qu'on a appris
depuis deux semaines c'est à dire qu'il
avait été extrêmement proche du pouvoir
chinois pendant plusieurs années et que
au sein de sa propre fondation on avait
parlé de la Fondation Trudeau mais lui a
créé la Fondation rideau lorsqu'il a
quitté ses fonctions de gouverneur
général et dans la Fondation rideau il y
a essentiellement le gratin des
relations Canada Chine y compris la
famille de Power Corporation et
plusieurs plusieurs signaux Canadiens
qui sont engagés là-dedans donc
au delà au-delà de la partie sonnerie
parce qu'il y a de la partisanerie dans
ce dossier là au-delà la partisanerie il
y a fondamentalement un doute sur la
crédibilité de Monsieur Johnson exact
que je n'avais pas au début OK puis même
bon la Fondation Trudeau puis le
stationnement sur le mont Royal ça me
dérangeait pas beaucoup mais de savoir
qu'il avait une proximité avec le
pouvoir chinois ces dernières années
ça change la perspective
si vous voyez le dossier à charge d'un
de vos grands amis vous trouvez ça moins
grave que si c'est le dossier à charge
de quelqu'un que vous ne connaissez pas
vous avez une tendance empathique et moi
je pense qu'il est crédible de dire il a
développé envers les Chinois une
empathie telle qu'il peut sous-estimer
la gravité d'un certain nombre
d'informations et effectivement
lorsqu'on lit son rapport c'est un
rapport qui minimise l'impact de chacune
des informations qu'on ne lues dans de
l'eau Benelli et dans global alors on se
dit bah lui il y a eu la totalité de la
preuve donc il y a une meilleure
compréhension de la chose mais comme il
le dit même c'est son interprétation de
l'interprétation des analystes de la
preuve brute on se dit mais là à deux à
deux éléments de distance de
l'interprétation de base là
effectivement ça perspective
d'empathique envers la Chine peut avoir
joué pour minimiser les choses
ça a donné lieu à des échanges assez
corsés à la Chambre des communières ce
qui s'est passé ou ce qui se passe dans
ce dossier là écoutons un extrait des
échanges
est-ce
que la République c'est parce qu'il n'a
plus personne qui est membre la
Fondation Trudeau
on a assez déjà en masse pour demander
un enquête vraiment indépendante
publique Polynésie son chum monsieur le
Président et le chef du Bloc québécois
qui est juste de dire au moins c'est
déjà en mars mais la réalité monsieur le
Président c'est qu'il ne le sait pas
parce qu'il a refusé de recevoir des
breffage sur les renseignements
confidentiels
ok juste un truc de imiter François
Blanchet du Bloc québécois c'est quand
même particulier juste pour en rajouter
en anglais juste un Trudeau a dit de
pierre poyièvre qu'il aime entendre sa
voix quand il pose des questions c'est
ça en aller là
ajouter si Justin Trudeau était du
chocolat
il se mangerait lui-même mais
franchement c'était vraiment pas fort
vraiment Dimitri
revenons alors sur la distraction de
distraction des vieux Johnson
hier vous avez posté la question
Sébastien qu'est-ce qui va se passer sur
le vote passe je vous dis rien ou
quelque chose donc quelque chose s'est
passé
super
donc début Johnson essentiellement a dit
à la Chambre des communes vous n'êtes
pas mon patron
donc encore une fois posons-nous la
question suivante monsieur johnsten va
pondre un rapport au mois d'octobre
est-ce que ce rapport sera crédible la
réponse est non donc là je m'en vais sur
le côté des institutions David johnsteen
qui était le plus haut représentant de
toutes les institutions canadiennes en
tant que gouverneur général le
ce qu'il dit qu'il respecte les
institutions est une contradiction avec
ses actions parce que l'institution des
élus démocratiquement lui ont dit malgré
le fait que nous nous avons pas embauché
on vous envoie un message au nom de ceux
qui nous représentons la majorité des
Canadiens que nous n'avons pas confiance
en vous et il leur dit c'est pas vous
qui m'avez engagé c'est le gouvernement
qui m'a engagé puis j'ai des comptes à
rendre au gouvernement vous l'achetez
pas exact et exact à 1500 dollars par
jour donc ça va être mon dernier point
ça va être mon dernier point donc
quelqu'un qui dit je ne m'en respect
pour les institutions il fait le
contraire de ses déclarations il fait le
contraire de ces déclarations parce que
malgré le fait que c'est vrai ce n'est
pas la Chambre des communes qu'il a
embauchée c'est Justin Trudeau il
devrait démissionner et finalement nous
allons dépenser des dizaines de millions
de dollars pour payer monsieur johnsten
et ses avocats libéraux
pour un rapport qui n'aura aucune
crédibilité
donc
à quelle fin à quelle fin est-ce qu'il
reste à quelle fin est-ce qu'il persiste
est signe sur un enjeu c'est important
de voir
de rester avec respect c'est pas lui de
décider son devoir vis-à-vis ses
responsabilités vis-à-vis le pays les
représentants du pays lui ont dit on ne
veut pas que vous assumez ce devoir
parce que vous êtes biaisé parce qu'on
n'a pas confiance en vous
Michel moi je le connais pas mais c'est
gentil mais c'est une orgueil un moment
donné est-ce que c'est ça je pense que
oui
il dit qu'il se donne une certaine
mission mais franchement aujourd'hui il
fait de la politique il fait peut-être
pas la partie zannerie depuis à
poilievre et compagnie mais il s'insère
dans la politique et en restant il fait
de la politique carrément et je
soupçonne qu'effectivement il y a une
bonne dose d'orgueil de dire non je ne
vais pas partir je vais pas quitter et
oui j'ai une mission mais Dimitri a
vraiment raison c'est c'est pas et c'est
pas logique de dire à quel point on
s'inscrit pour défendre les institutions
démocratiques en contrat l'ingérence
étrangère et en acceptant pas que 174
députés qui disent nous souhaiterions
que vous quittiez et nous vous demandons
de quitter et lui ne quitte pas alors
c'est mal finir une carrière
de toute évidence ou alors il fait sa
politique il va faire son rapport il va
le mettre au gouvernement Trudeau à
Monsieur Trudeau puis il va dire
débrouillez-vous c'est sa règle rien il
va comme c'est d'ailleurs Dimitri qui a
déjà dit il lui remet la patate chaude
et et chaudron il est plein de patates
chaudes alors on aura on aura vraiment
rien réglé c'est un extraordinaire
garanti tout ça pour ça et et souvent on
est matériel tout ça
on verra parce que il y aura quand même
des recommandations sur des actions il y
en aura des recommandations sur des
actions et on souhaite tous les quatre
on le dit que le gouvernement
ces actions là le plus rapidement
possible donc et c'est là-dessus que
mais monsieur Trudeau par rapport à ça
et et et vous savez quand on est on
finit une session avant Noël quand on
est au gouvernement on se dit toujours
quelle sera la discussion autour de la
dinde on essaie toujours de s'assurer
que on va quitter la session pour que la
diction autour de la dette soit en tour
de notre faveur mais là ça va être quoi
la discussion autour des barbecues cet
été mais Françoise a tellement raison
honnêtement il y a pas grand monde qui
est autour de son barbecue va parler de
l'ingérence étrangère mais et encore une
fois gouvernement achète du temps
monsieur Trudeau achète du temps il va
remettre son rapport il va avoir des
actions et on souhaite croise les doigts
que le gouvernement que ce soit de
bonnes actions même si elles sont pas
crédibles Dimitri ça peut être des
bonnes actions ça peut être des bonnes
recommandations et et le gouvernement va
espérer régler ça de cette façon là
rapidement
rapidement écoutez allez chercher
quelqu'un de l'externe c'est pour des
fins d'une enquête publique ou d'une
enquête judiciaire d'une revue
judiciaire embauché quelqu'un de
l'externe c'est comment embaucher
mckinzie pour dire au gouvernement pour
faire sur l'ingérence chinoise pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a besoin de dévidence pour
dire au gouvernement quoi faire sur
l'enjeu de l'ingérence chinoise c'est
deux sujets différents enquêter et
recommandé on s'entend mais il sait le
choix du gouvernement et depuis le début
d'une mauvaise nomination et faisons la
liste de toutes les mauvaises
nominations de ce gouvernement là c'est
assez fascinant
assume le rôle de premier ministre puis
qui fasse la job de l'histoire pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI